what's up babies today's podcast is
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
for less than $10 per person per meal
that's nothing that's nothing you pay
more going out to eat or or anything
else blue apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with the pre-portioned
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron dot-com / Congrats you will love
how good it feels and tastes in your
mouth to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait
that's blue apron dot-com / Congrats
blue apron is a better way to cook this
episode is also brought to you hmm
also or also I think also it's also
brought to you by Square cash if you
don't know what square cash is by now
you coud for real because right now I'm
telling you I've set it so much on this
podcast I if you're not switching to
this cash app then you are you mean
nothing to me
okay it's the best way to pay people
back most payments can be deposited to
your bank account in seconds if you use
other apps to pay people I you know it's
just not I don't I don't want you to be
doing that
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now
[Music]
babies what the [ __ ] hey pressure rush
out the plane I'm fresh off the plane
from Nashville fresh out the plane from
Cashville dude I I did it I came fresh
off the plane
extra paper scoop that up there's an LL
Cool J or song where he says fresh out
the private jet from Europe extra paper
scoop that up at saqqaq to say that
extra paper first of all is this a [ __ ]
and then to say he scooped it up is it's
a [ __ ] so I was think about that when I
say I got off the plane fresh off the
private jet from fresh off the private
jet from Europe extra paper scoop that
up like he's also asking the question
extra paper
scoop that up like VL how to cook like
hey I look cool what are you doing extra
paper alright just scoop it up freshen
up the private jet from Europe Scott so
but yeah I went to I was in Nashville
and I just got back sat down recording
from my babies that's it dude mommy's
loud and clear right now
daddy's loud and clear right now so
that's what I'm doing - that's what I'm
doing for you guys because I want you to
get that some of you guys late night
vampires are gonna be listening to this
and I I really really enjoy that you're
gonna be doing that and I'm here for you
I could have up could have put it out on
Tuesdays could have done it cuz that's
what I said in the beginning I would I
would give you guys at least by Tuesday
but I've been pretty good about doing it
at least late Monday um a lot of people
have been coming up to me saying I'm a
baby which is [ __ ] hilarious still to
me
grown men walking up and saying hey man
I'm a baby or from across the street I'm
a baby and it's so funny not know
knowing that not everybody knows about
the podcast and everyone else looking at
that guy and thinking the [ __ ] is wrong
with that lunatic so but that just shows
the support the full [ __ ]
cult support that you guys are [ __ ]
doing it and you guys we are organizing
and we are getting together my goal is
to get the government to come after me
on this [ __ ] okay because it's like
a cult
so but yeah I was in Nashville and got
off the I was in LA in Nashville and now
Nashville is a great city I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna it's a great city it
really is it's it's probably one of the
best cities in America now with that
being said I'm about to [ __ ] all over it
okay cuz it's a comedy podcast one time
oh wait I did a show in Nashville I was
making fun of Nashville and I was I was
doing I did eight shows by the way I had
five shows and then I was just gonna do
a little run but then it sold out very
quickly so I added two more it sold out
very quickly so I added one more all
right
I did eight shows mmm so one of so you
know I'd open up I always open up
talking about the city well usually and
and somebody was like yo you made fun of
my city man that's not [ __ ] cool hey
man don't go to a comedy shop real quick
real quick don't go to a comedy show
Nashville is great though and it's got
some here's the deal these cities are
weird though it's Nashville's feel in
itself which is super [ __ ]
flamboyantly annoying okay super [ __ ]
annoying that it's Philly I don't like
to see these that feel themselves this
is Nashville this is Austin this is
Denver this is San Francisco now you
probably say what about Los Angeles in
New York yeah but those cities are too
big that it swallows everything else
okay I also cities where everyone's
always talking about how great they are
and makes me real mad and in New York
they do that but New York is just so
[ __ ] big this is a conglomeration I
called death row and New York is just
like in New York this is the best
[ __ ] city in the world and they've
you know and you're just like yeah okay
I've been to a lot of places but
Nashville
you'll be there and people be like in
Nashville great
and you're just like yeah let me just
[ __ ] chill out and eat my [ __ ]
Subway sandwich alright but you got to
admit Nashville ain't that great yeah
yeah yeah and so anyway uh I since so I
they have this I didn't go I actually
did didn't go I walked through it the
Broadway area where they've got [ __ ]
just bars every bar they're on both
sides of the street has [ __ ] live
music in in it cool it you don't have
had to yeah I guess what don't have all
the live music in the same [ __ ] place
know why because then it all sounds like
noise okay have a [ __ ] bar with live
music on it far away from another bar
without music in it this way if you're
standing outside about the bars
you don't hear - honky tonk boys [ __ ]
screaming out lyrics okay
country music um you know make it about
other things don't just make it about
dude they should make a country song
about love dude they should make a
country song about love and a girl a guy
should sing about a girl a guy should
sing about a girl that that that he
loves or a girl that he missed an
opportunity with that's what somebody
should make a country song about or you
know what a girl should make a country
song about a guy that did him around
dude where's that country song where's
the country song about the girl that
where the guy did him wrong and she's
about to do a two-step on his face
where's the country song about the girl
fallen in love huh hey country songs
hick punch songs make more songs about
love so many songs about love dude I
love her pamper him around I'm a
honky-tonk lover Brent brown solanki
talk honky-tonk
ah dude it's [ __ ] shonky talk man
it's a honky-tonk honky-tonk eleven prey
number two Brown you walk down Broadway
and that's one thing and then you've
walked two steps in this virgon ah
I [ __ ] he did me wrong he did me wrong
I took a bat to his TV a brown
background and then you walk two more
feet and then it's like is this the
[ __ ] first song yeah but other songs
are about honky Tonk Man or a dude doing
the girl long Brown become Brown country
is about the same [ __ ] [ __ ] is about the
same [ __ ] bring home breaking ground
breaking Braemar to bring her all around
you know what I would listen to this son
country song that was called countries
about the same [ __ ] and I would listen
to all the Lord's country is about the
same [ __ ] as the song before you just
heard a country song so why are you
listening to this one - here's the same
song brown butter brown I don't get down
do it and you walk out in the live bars
if you're gonna have music in your bar
have music in your bar but don't open
the [ __ ] doors and windows so every
time I walk by it's like I'm in the bar
because it's so loud and I just want to
walk down the middle of the street with
both of my hands out with both of my
fingers up extended to each side of the
[ __ ] honky Tonk Broadway and just
giving the [ __ ] bird to each and
every bar honky tonk loving [ __ ] you he
did me wrong [ __ ] you more like a town
11 [ __ ] you that's how it goes that's
how the walk goes and oh here's another
thing Nashville and I was talking about
this on stage don't call it nashvegas
okay why now let me give you the blanket
reason why because it's sad now why is
it so sad
well because you can't claim to be one
of the baddest cities in the world one
of the greatest cities in the country
so then don't use another city's name to
join in to make the name with your city
because then you're basically saying hey
we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ] and the
other city is better that's what you're
saying
that's what you're saying hey nashvegas
that's [ __ ] stupid the first guy who
thought of that must have [ __ ] himself
must have been like [ __ ] dude this
ain't even Nashville this [ __ ]
nashvegas and then everyone else went
wow and then one guy had a heart attack
and like had to like sit down for a
little bit at a mini little mini heart
attack he was like oh [ __ ] mine actually
can't believe you made such a [ __ ]
cool ass discovery ting oh [ __ ] man I
thought I was honky-tonk but you came up
with that nice bag of [ __ ] nope
guess what I'm gonna call it now Nash
Dakota is what I'm calling it you're
gonna call it nashvegas every time I
hear someone say nashvegas I'm gonna
[ __ ] say oh you mean Nash Dakota
oh you mean Nash Aska you mean Nash
Coover actually that place is [ __ ]
dope you have to pick bad places
I don't know Nash Jersey what is it
what's like Las Vegas in Nashville can
you gamble no can you [ __ ] hookers no
can you kill dead bodies and [ __ ]
cover it up
no is the first 48 often taking place in
your city on the outskirts yes but in
Nashville no I love how Nashville is
like one [ __ ] blue dot in the middle
of a Red Sea like you can just be in
Nashville and be like um come on oh I
want about to know and just be [ __ ]
sucking dudes dicks and everybody's cool
and that's awesome and be liberal as
[ __ ] and then if you take like three
steps out of the [ __ ] out of gnash
Dakota people are like
I will you think you're doing around
here your long hair boy or like you get
a little sweet on that boy aren't you
you're like uh take three steps back
yeah so Oh
but anyway we were cool it was cool to
be there I had a good time there I was
staying in a hotel and then the other my
other two openers were staying at the
condo across the street and um I mean
these guys are just [ __ ] these guys
are a laugh dude you know what these
guys are a laugh they're a laugh I mean
they're like Mike and Mark first of all
their names are there like somebody said
this I remember who it was but they're
like the two [ __ ] idiots in Ocean's
eleven then they are or they're just
like talking about [ __ ] that doesn't
matter who was it a Affleck the Affleck
kid and the con was it who was I don't
know but it was to him they were always
bumbling and you're and that's who they
are
um they're great guys one of them Irish
Mark dude he [ __ ] sweats so much but
when he laughs it's like he's a [ __ ]
black comedian in the middle of his set
like and I'm talking about when he
laughs at a diner he sweats so much it's
unbelievable and and and the word he
uses to describe the the best thing like
the the like if something's great but
better than great he'll say unreal
that's how I got the Unreal pants think
you'd be like oh those pants are unreal
and he's and but he'll anything he'll be
like always that was it unreal like
we'll be at a [ __ ] was the [ __ ]
what's that crowd good was it unreal
it's unbelievable son
believable but the shows were great
would it be [ __ ] laugh at we were
good there early we're at the [ __ ]
show or we were at the airport early and
[ __ ] was he saying
I don't remember we were laughing but we
were laughing so [ __ ] hard that mark
was laughing so hard he was sweating so
[ __ ] much dude and then we started
laughing that he was sweating so much
and then we would we couldn't stop
laughing he couldn't stop sweating and
he was so wet by the end of it sing
criminais ting that i'm saying this on
the podcast and now y'all know that i
have a sweaty opener but yeah and so so
oh god it's so [ __ ] hot in this room
it's so hot in this room dude and my
[ __ ] producer who was a nice guy came
over while I was gone and [ __ ] did
you know some [ __ ] yeah at that for the
podcast at my house and then when he
left he was like hey man just to let you
know that you're keeping the air on and
you shouldn't be keeping the air on and
I was like oh yeah so I turned the air
off remotely with my phone because mmm
James Bond okay and then and then when I
got home to do this podcast
the place was 157 degrees so I was
looking after I spent [ __ ] 35 minutes
looking for boa constrictors i sat down
to do this podcast now since the
producer told me to turn off the air and
then I got back and now the airs not on
it's 157 degrees and I had to look for
Bo constrictors for 35 minutes one fire
them now it's cool okay but one fire
he's a nice guy one fire um but you know
it's all good anyway oh dude but I
[ __ ] forget I always want to lead
with this and I don't lead with this so
i we got new t-shirts in you Kudus and
new freak conch and we got all its agora
congratulations or go to Chris Leo calm
and get the [ __ ] stuff and all that
my opener was getting sick so it's
always cool as a comedian when your
opener gets sick
cuz he goes on before you and gets the
microphone [ __ ] all high jinks top
and then you got to go onstage and the
whole time you're [ __ ] even though
your kick even though you're [ __ ]
even though you're [ __ ] and making
the crowd laugh and they're loving you
and they're like say more say more you
know and people are falling down and
people are crying oh my god
even though that's when there are little
[ __ ] flu bacteria crawling into your
mouth and that's all you're thinking
about even though you're there still
crawling bacteria your mother you know
you're about to get the flu so but the
[ __ ] zany's is a cool club dude it's
it's a cool club and it that late Friday
night show there are always pieces of
[ __ ] in it always pieces of [ __ ] in it
man there was one chick that was just
talking way too loud and I said hey you
gotta shut the [ __ ] up and everyone got
weird then I tried to go into my act and
it was definitely weird for another
minute oh yeah I [ __ ] sorry guys but
I had to [ __ ] stop the pockets and
take my shirt off I'm sorry and I know
you so here it may have been a little
bit of a jump cut right there I don't
know but it was getting so [ __ ] hot
in this room cuz my producer one fire
him but he I had to take off my t-shirt
and I know that obviously now you know
I'm doing my t-shirt my podcast is on my
t-shirt on and you can definitely
[ __ ] probably feel the sexual energy
anyway it's gonna be a little bit super
sexy I'm a little bit more super sexy
from now on so sorry about that
but whatever I deal with deal with you
know what I mean dude when I was at the
airport when I was coming back from the
airport today I was in in [ __ ] Nash
Tuco
and I [ __ ] was waiting to get in
through the TSA and if the something
nests elcio it happened and that this
[ __ ] I hear this voice go because I'm
putting my [ __ ] a computer in the bin
separately I'm taking it on my bag even
though it doesn't matter and I'm putting
my toiletries in the little plastic bags
and put anything doesn't matter either
because nothing happening but you still
might do that and I take my shoes off
and I'm putting it in a bin because you
got two cashews off in that doesn't
matter so so I did that and while I'm
doing all those things I absolutely
don't matter so the Apple I'm doing
those things I hear from behind this kid
say excuse me I'm 14 am I allowed to go
through there and dude I looked over and
I and I first of all it warmed I've
warmed my heart because 100% the kids
saying any won't ever say because they
say excuse me sir I'm 14 is absolutely
adorable okay but then also say and not
saying should I go through there but
saying am I allowed to go through there
is a polite and also adorable okay
that's it warmed my heart then I turned
around looked at the kid and I saw
myself in that kid and I thought that's
so cute he's traveling with his family
and I traveled with my family and the
kids weren't shorts and he's got an
obvious [ __ ] knees and a [ __ ] bad
haircut and a great t-shirt but it made
me [ __ ] almost cry because the kid
was warming my heart because he said
that he has no idea did that he has no
idea pie doesn't remember what he said
also he had an orange suitcase don't
have an urn suitcase anyway my point is
the kid was so dorky but it was so cute
how I heard it first and then expected
it the big turn around now 14 year olds
also let me tell you something you're
not cute if you're a 14 year old unless
it's you know your parents think you're
cute but 14 year olds look dorky as [ __ ]
okay when someone's 14 their heads too
big their knees are too big their shoes
are too big and you know they got
pimples all over their faces but this
kid said the thing first I heard it am I
allowed to go through there talking
about the x-ray thing oh of course
you're allowed what the [ __ ] you're a
human we got to know if you have bombs
on you but it was so cute man so then I
went back and I grabbed my computer put
it back in the bag you know doesn't
matter I took my [ __ ] shoes put him
back on even it doesn't matter and also
put my toe shoes back in with top K you
know it doesn't matter also um yeah but
it was very cute it was very very cute
it was very very cute I don't like to
get political on this podcast but I
can't believe I mean all of Twitter and
Instagram is so [ __ ] political right
now it's so [ __ ] up what's going on
it's so [ __ ] crazy what's happening
all the crazy pictures of like the black
cop and then the white supremacist
behind them and then I today the other
day I saw or noted I'm sorry - not the
other day today I saw pictures of like
[ __ ] I saw a picture with a black cop
I think was like two black cops trying
to like talk to this [ __ ]
two-year-old with a KKK outfit on the
[ __ ] baby who's white supremacist
like didn't even know any better like
well what the [ __ ] the kid could barely
say the kid could barely say that n-word
and he's a [ __ ] racist no it was so
[ __ ] sad and also like weird that
some piece of [ __ ] would dress their
their son in a KKK outfit like some
little kid is just like like some kid
like like no kid ever said some [ __ ]
like I don't like Koreans like because
they're too young I only like my kind
like no [ __ ] kid ever said that I
don't like the people who are different
colors I only like a pale people I only
like people who don't have who I only
lie why people I mean it was so [ __ ]
up I'm making light of it you know
whatever but it's it was so [ __ ] up
that these and that you know God imagine
seeing that in in actual life like
seeing a [ __ ] clue clock a Ku Klux is
a Ku Klux or clue ku klux cool hey
change it
Oh Ku Klux Klan change it hey that's the
biggest problem with your organization
okay imagine being like dude imagine
like just listen to that sentence
actually like take an alien coming down
to earth and being like all dressed up
as a human and being like and talking to
another alien now that other alien has
no idea what any organizations are right
and the alien says seriously to the
other alien hey I've really given this a
lot of thought and I really want to join
the Ku Klux course it's actually even
hard to say in like earn-in an earnest
way hey mom dad I been thinking about it
for quite some time and you may not
agree with it but I really want to be a
member of the Ku Klux Klan hey [ __ ]
wrestler
that's a dumb [ __ ] name okay also no
matter what organization you are don't
wear pointy hats okay oh they cover your
face dorks
oh you got robes dorks oh you look like
Orko grew feet and threw his [ __ ]
laundry and the in in with the whites
you're a dork okay you're a [ __ ] dork
oh you dressed your kid up to be a white
supremacist hey kids aren't supreme at
anything except for [ __ ] their pants
so put pants on them not cloaks bye look
mom
dad I really been thinking about joining
the Ku Klux Klan oh well you can't join
that cuz the [ __ ] stupidest [ __ ] name
so anyway can you join something else
like a federation of something oh man
anyway so now they're after me probably
you know it's weird that though that the
they think like we're all like
everyone's like you shouldn't be racist
they're not ready you know don't be
racist but the white supremacists don't
think that they're racist they think
that they're the [ __ ] well sorry I
almost turned into a dragon I don't know
if you heard that but I had a [ __ ]
thing going out of me in my chest and
all that [ __ ] cool it's gross
but they think that they're the object
of where all the racism is coming from
they think that what they're doing is
right dude
it's never right to dress up a baby as
anything except on Halloween dressed
them up as a vampire so I do it I just
don't I don't understand them quite
understand it but you know I grew up a
little differently than maybe those
people but I am white like those people
which is weird and it makes me feel
weird being white and it also is hard to
not feel guilty about it too even though
I know I don't do that [ __ ] like I just
don't want to be associated with those
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
it's just weird it's a weird [ __ ]
time for everybody man it really [ __ ]
is and I'd love to how the [ __ ] it
feels like everybody's doing everything
wrong though man like the Liberals like
took down the statue and like we're
kicking the statue hard like you're just
hurting your foot dude you're gonna
break your foot and also then you make
liberals look violent I get it there's a
lot of pent up emotion but
I don't know this is too serious I'm not
I mean anyway anyway white supremacy is
bad have you guys tried to lift lift
knows that their drivers are what keep
them moving
literally and emotionally so they do
everything that they can to make sure
their drivers are happy on every tip
it's a simple formula happy drivers mean
happy passengers maybe that's why nine
out of ten lyft rights gets a perfect
five star rating um hello I don't like
to do that a lot but that deserves a
lift rides get a perfect five star
rating um hello
lyft was the first ride share platform
with tipping built right into the app
okay the other ones copied so that must
mean that lyft is the best okay by the
way tip shouldn't depend on your
passenger having a crumpled-up bill in
their pocket Express pay lets you get
paid almost instantly instead of waiting
for weeks
join the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
go to lift calm / Congrats today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus that's
lyft dot-com / Congrats
lyft calm / Congrats limited time only
terms of life
five four is this company a five-four
Club okay under it understands that your
tights a clothing company it understands
that your time is extremely valuable and
why wasted at the mall or wandering
around in this in the stores dude have
you been to a mall recently oh it's like
that movie Strange Days with ray Fiennes
also that guy's name should be Ralph P
Ennis they've been lead they've been the
leading men's wear brand for 15 years
and you could trust him with your
wardrobe you think our hot styles man I
wear a few of their shirts all the time
they sent me some stuff each in each
month they send you a box of to three
items that are hand-picked to match the
current season and your style so if you
complete dork which are probably you let
these guys help you they've been helping
men with fashion for over 15 years and
ship up 200 ship to over 100,000 men
every month they know what they're doing
if you don't that's fine if you don't
cuz your dork they do because you're fat
the help you build your wardrobe one
month at a time you get $120 worth of
clothes for just 60 bucks a month pause
or cancel anytime Chris Paul and Mark
Wahlberg use five for Club and five for
is featured in GQ vison InStyle go to
five for club calm right now and enter
promo code Congrats and they'll give you
50% off your first month's package plus
a free pair of sunglasses what that's
50% off your first package at 5:00 for
club spelled F I ve f oh you are
club.com promo code Congrats five for
club.com promo code Congrats
so so what's up
Mark Wahlberg Mark Wahlberg says did you
send me God do it
Mark Wahlberg does that I think what is
it DirecTV thing I look it up I think he
does the DirecTV thing that was me just
ripping up my headshot he does a thing
and it's so funny because you can fit
he's like talking about like you know
DirecTV has the most has the most genres
the mute of movies or whatever he says
it's like DirecTV has the most genres of
music of movies is it it's AT&T okay so
it's an AT&T thing whatever but he's
talking about watching movies and John
and genres and movies and he's like you
can watch more movies and he walks
through a war thing and we got much
action movies and these walks through a
like an action thing and he's like oh
you walk through huh you can walk
through it or you can watch a lot of
different movies and that one the
romance one he says or you could watch
romance and my favorite thing is I know
he added this part after the romance
thing he says you can watch a lot of
romance if you're into that if you're
into that kind of thing and I know he
added it there's no way because he's the
man you know I mean he's walking through
the romantic than people kissing on the
beach and he says or you could watch
romance and then he says if you're into
that sort of thing and I love the fact
that the the 18 t people or whatever it
is DirecTV 18 t they're like oh we don't
want you to say that
like oh yeah that's fine but I'm still
gonna do it I'm gonna kick your [ __ ]
ass and they're like ah okay
listen I'm not romantic I'm a
blockbuster all right if you tell me to
say what's a romantic movie that takes
my street cred down a few notches I'm
gonna kick your [ __ ] ass if you cut
it out and they're like since they're
all definitely [ __ ] dorks they're
like okay well let's just listen oh
that's what I [ __ ] thought I don't
have to kick your ass already got my
workout in today
I beat up some people already um I look
at HBO kid stuff come on but just want
all the stuff we say I want all the
stuff what is there I mean got this the
TMT brings you DirecTV internet and
wireless all on your terms it's
entertainment your way just trying to
read it didn't really do it too well
anyway uh so Mark Wahlberg does that any
punches have some robots in the
commercial you know what right were
looking for so I'm talking about I don't
know I don't really see it like on the
audience channel or some [ __ ] I have no
idea there's so many outlets and [ __ ] I
feel like Tinder's gonna have a [ __ ]
streaming service soon like hey I got a
[ __ ] show coming out on tinder oh
really
yeah what's it about oh it's about a
down-and-out cop that's just like front
you know he disrupts the system because
he like punches people out and and and
talks and says that it says [ __ ] in
court and you're like on tinder yeah I
got a [ __ ] new show streaming on
tinder it's gonna be nominated for an
Emmy it's about it's the shield they're
remaking they're doing they're doing the
prequel to the shield I mean you're
that's a joke I guarantee some [ __ ] like
that's gonna happen I want to talk about
something though that's came up the
other day to me I've got a lot of people
doing a lot of cool artwork and just
fans and [ __ ] you know babies do an
artwork and and showing their support in
the podcast
this one this one account i retweeted it
it's it's a fan account and this guy let
me see if I could find it this guy did a
it's called see D'Elia Photoshop it's
not my didn't do it but he made this
song called definition of a CUDA and I
and I was talking about how when I first
said yeah that's the definition of a
CUDA I said that's like a Tupac song
definition of a CUDA and I was thinking
about another song when he what he says
it I forget what song he says didn't I
don't know but anyway I forget what he's
a definition of it and now I remember
what the real thing is but anyway he
took a different song I think it's
troublesome I think I don't know but oh
whatever it is I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know I should know because I
love Tupac but this CUDA thing is kind
of so he so this guy tweeted if Tupac
wrote a track for Chris Lea this this
would be it and hashtag definition of a
CUDA i retweeted it a lot of you guys
heard it already but I'm gonna play it
for you so here's the deal with this
[ __ ] song I did not write this and
this is not me rapping this is a guy
that did this and made this and put it
to a Tupac beat that's already out and
it's really it made me laugh so hard cuz
in this song these lyrics this guy's
definitely listen to every if you
listened to every podcast so far you
know that how intricate this song is so
I'm gonna play this song for you now and
then you're gonna have a laugh so here
it is definition of a coup the
definition of a coup de
[Music]
the definition of a cooler here's a song
goes out to my family the definition of
a Crudup
[Music]
a real food and I do yourself a favor
anger gunk Fukuda definition of a food
up
[Music]
ence intricate and dude got lots of
downtime huh
but this guy's account is really funny
because he does lots of photo shops like
he's the one that did the picture of me
and United [ __ ] the one United airplane
[ __ ] me I don't know and then he did
another thing a country album crystally
crystally is sucking and [ __ ] they
photoshop my head on some [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] outfit like what is that outfit
I mean you know Siddeley a Photoshop you
know hey man see the LIA Photoshop like
she all submitting it but you do not
change it listen to me now do not change
it because that that's what it is man
live your [ __ ] life dude what a baby
that guy is though and we haven't
announced elders but it's [ __ ] like that
that that's gonna that's gonna you know
get get chin [ __ ] daddy or mommy's
good graces and I'm either one you want
you know so so we haven't announced an
elder yet but we will be doing that soon
and thinking about doing it really
really really really really soon so I
don't know man whatever I want to talk
to you about a company called naturebox
now I like to call it nature box because
I pretend that those ends are mmm
because that's so yummy all right we
won't want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks sometimes it feels like
the whole world is delicious in a
billion calorie sources boring and
tasteless now you don't want boring and
tasteless but you don't want delicious
and billions of calories it doesn't have
to be that way nature box has over a
hundred snacks that's triple digits
amounts of snacks that taste good and
are actually better for you all snacks
are made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners so you can
feel good about what you're reading
my I like the salt and vinegar veggie
chips and Asiago and cheddar cheese
crisps now obviously a British guy named
that because he said crisps but I like
those because I like cheese because
cheese makes everything better
but Asiago change it you're sure to find
your yeah don't call your cheese Asiago
it's tunas too many vowels you're sure
to find your new snap and snack
obsession at naturebox they add new
snacks every month that's why I Drive
real inspired by real customer feedback
the latest food trends and professional
chefs it's real simple go to the nature
box calm and then they'll deliver them
right to your door there's no risks you
don't like it well don't eat it will
replace it they'll replace it for free
right now you'll save even more but you
probably like oh this is gonna cost
$14,000 right no it doesn't next is
offering congrats fans three free snacks
with your first order when you go to
nature box.com slash Congrats that's
nature box calm
for three free snacks with your first
order nature box calm
do you guys know blue apron you did cuz
you first turned on the podcast and
that's what I talked about in beginning
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the conch you understand in the
country in this free conch blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone and take
it from me they did it blue apron has
established partnerships in over 150
local farms fisheries and ranchers
across the United States that means
everything's better the seafood seafood
is sourced sustainably the beef chicken
and pork pork come from responsibly
raised animals and the produce is
sourced from farms that practice
regenerative farming featured upcoming
meals yeah watch your mouth water watch
it watch your mouth water
featuring upcoming meals watch your
mouth water when I say this basil pesto
chicken with summer vegetable Penza
nella oh YUM sauteed shrimp and green
beans with globe tomatoes spinach and
Orso pasta oh come on
hey check this one out miso butter
salmon and lo mein noodles with cucumber
and charm tomatoes you ever had a charm
tomato if you haven't you down now a
good taste tastes like meatball pizza
with fresh mozzarella and or as I like
to say mozzarella cheese and charm
tomatoes again how many charm tomatoes
do they have dude check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron dot-com slash Congrats
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron Sadam wait that's
blue apron dot-com / Congrats blue apron
a better way to cook charm tomatoes do
it I'll eat those
hey globe tomatoes really you try like
just call them circular tomatoes or
spherical tomatoes globe tomatoes oh
yeah globe tomatoes really where can I
find South Africa on you tomato oh I
can't sit tomato and then Square cash
everyone is squid swish switching to the
school to the cash shop squishing or
switching swishing switching to the cash
up do it dude square cash it's the best
way to pay people back friends family
coworkers
demons lizards a wizard sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly in your bank account seconds
Square cash is better than the other
guys and it's not a social network who
wants to have their payments listed in a
feed not me not a kuda it's not Facebook
download the free square cash app for
iOS and Android now alright look guys
we're getting lots of work done here
okay cuz my back is sweating like and
like it's so insane the back of my chair
is a waterslide
hey dude let me look back and see if
there's people waiting in line to get in
to Six Flags
oh dude hey guys oh man so my producer
got up and just left the room because
he's hot 2 1 fire him I'll just sit it
out hey dude can you get my la crop my
Lacroix please
milah croaks it's it's out there no it's
already out there it's out there
somewhere is it on my you got it cool
cuz you want to go open the fridge and
want a firearm because I said it's out
there already buddy I went to go up in
the fridge someone farm but anyway
thanks dude
oh you brought so I could wipe my back
cool
it's gross anyway you know be funny if
podcasters were so good at podcasting
that they got chicks from it you know
but yeah do it I by the way I've been
getting so many [ __ ] up Instagram
posts of the week
people send me them all the time and
every time I look at them it's it's just
unbelievable let me let me let me look
up some here well no I guess there's
only gonna be one so here we go you guys
ready this is the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post to the week now god I
want to say these peoples names so bad
but I can't I mean it's just I don't
want to put on buzz you guys find him
anyway but hmm all right so here's a
girl she's got a bunch of followers and
now this is what the comment is or the
caption is you want something go for it
with a savage heart a courageous mind Oh
a courageous mindset and a gentle tongue
people will see your perseverance truth
and dedication you don't need to scream
it to them dude so besides the fact that
I when she said gentle tongue my insides
boiled besides the fact that I got BRM
from her sang gentle tongue
like I imagine her saying gentle tongue
and then being like but what's another
word for gentle and then like googled
the thesaurus for gentle and then was
going through a bunch of words and just
thought you know what it's probably just
best and most simple if I just say
gentle okay also real bad advice why do
you have to be quiet about it
you don't need to just you don't need to
scream it to them okay cool man also she
didn't say did she say this I don't know
I feel like this is a quote by like
[ __ ] TS Eliot okay and here's the
picture she's dressed like an Indian and
she's not Indian or maybe she is but she
saw a dressed-up she's got a machine gun
in the picture and it's in a chain
that's like a Hercules chain and
feathers in her hair and then she writes
I'm ready for another experiment in
savagery this chick kind of just chills
out you know what I mean she just kind
of chills out she just kind of goes and
eats with her friends okay you know just
probably chills out on a couch I'm look
at the her Instagram she's a model I
guess she there's some her sipping on a
nice an iced latte or something here's
another selfie of her in a bikini
experiment in savagery you know what is
that
i-ight if I find if I ever see her in
real life I'm gonna say hey hey what do
you mean experiment in savagery and
where's your
[ __ ] feathers and a machine gun I
wish she dressed like that in real in
real life Alma look through these
hashtags here right now and a
congratulations pod gaming the system by
the way the guy who created the gaming
the system hashtag or wait no he didn't
create the hashtag but he said he was
the first guy who said gaming the system
he says too easy to game the system III
forgot I didn't know who he was and then
he tweeted me again and he was like hey
do you think I should be an elder
because I was the one who first had
gamed the system so funny and also you
know I don't know man ok so uh here are
some things here's one dude I don't even
know people it's so funny that the
things that you guys think I should
weigh in on are like sometimes to me
they I don't know why some things work
me and something but like some of the
things you say like hey dude what do you
think about a guy that wears a yellow
shirt one day and then the red shirt the
next day and it's like yeah but that
doesn't work me you know this one
doesn't really bug me although I could
see how you could think it might but I'm
not even bringing this guy thing up
because this guy's the ultimate change
it of all time well no actually he
doesn't I still think that other girl
was the most I forget what it was but it
was a few episodes ago I can't remember
what the [ __ ] it was but I couldn't
believe the change it that she had going
on this guy's name is Dookie spreader
Dookie spreader dude and his profile is
first of all his face looks so much like
a guy that would [ __ ] have a handle
called Dookie spreader by the way his
name is Dookie spreader and his [ __ ]
thing is Dookie spreader hey man you got
problems you got prize okay and this guy
Dookie spreader okay and what are the
three icons under the thing dude you see
those three icons what even are those
oh the Frog okay cool alright this is
what it says on his thing and lost it
what fire him do the producer man just
look you know he took it out and lost it
so it's all good
tweeted seventy five times since he
tweeted that so anyway he was asking
what my thoughts on ankle socks were
which aren't a big deal to me I mean
here's the deal yeah actually I do ever
thought about any go socks I don't think
that they're that big of a deal alright
if you're gonna wear ankle socks you can
wear ankle socks I think you pretty much
should only wear them if you got low
tops on because y-you weren't ankle
socks if you got [ __ ] high tops on
but I don't feel that strongly about
that but here's what I do feel strongly
about if you go to someone's house and
you take off your shoes and you have
ankle socks on you take those goddamn
ankle socks off to you never walk around
in just ankle socks even if you're alone
cuz that's some [ __ ] serious Dom you
you look you're a [ __ ] basically you're
a [ __ ] mark ass [ __ ] alone in your
house you can't be a mark ass [ __ ]
alone in your house if you if you're at
home you need to work on being the least
mark ass [ __ ] possible because if
you're a mark ass [ __ ] at home you're
gonna be a mark ass [ __ ] out in the
wild do you understand me
alright so that's the rule dude take the
[ __ ] foreshore take the [ __ ]
anchor socks off if you take your
[ __ ] shoes off what else we got my
guess is what this guy Nick Sanderson at
Nick swag at N swag erson oh dude and
change it oh wait by the way the Dookie
spreader guy couldn't look more like a
guy whose face that would be like think
it's cool to coat did you say Dookie
spreader and also he's buried in sand
and under his face somebody made sand
castle tits
hey guy be more you
oh you can't kill here's a Nick Swardson
do you enjoy animated sitcoms at all
like South Park for example my guess is
no lol
I love South Park through South Park is
if you don't like South Park if you
think South Park is not funny
I can't understand what what happened in
your life to make you think that I used
to have a [ __ ] buddy that didn't like
South Park
I'm actually not his friend anymore
because he's piece of [ __ ] but not
because of the South Park thing but just
goes to show you you don't like South
Park you piece of [ __ ]
South Park is the [ __ ] and how do
they keep making stuff that's relevant
and so funny so [ __ ] funny here's
another one Artur Stoffel I mean what
kind of a name is Artur put the H in it
um you know at our church Stoffel oh hey
man you forgot the H in your handle and
also your name think so oh but the agent
it dude my name's Arthur oh dude he
misses it Arthur okay so Arthur Stoffel
it sounds too German to me Artur still
follow hello I am artis Terfel is
everything all good of course it is why
wouldn't it be good everything is
absolutely fine where's the h i poisoned
it where's the agent name I don't know I
haven't seen it in quite some time I
promise you that maybe it took a
sabbatical maybe it went somewhere for
vacation maybe I poisoned it fair sir H
I haven't seen it in quite some time now
and Stoffel makes me think of stoves
stovetop what was that [ __ ] thing
stovetop cooking or whatever oh that
[ __ ] made me so hungry when I was a kid
made me hungry
any thoughts on people who use the
phrase story of my life on a regular
basis great question here's the deal man
if you are some kind of [ __ ] person
that says story of my life ingest your
egos out of control you don't have a
story about your
okay your life is your life if you say
story of my life and you're not
Huck Finn hey um if you don't say if you
say story of my life and you're not
[ __ ] the main character in their eyes
were watching God by Zora Neale Hurston
then you know what don't say but also if
you say you know that's the [ __ ]
story of my life
like exasperated and you're like I'm at
a loss then I think it's okay
[ __ ] story my life man I can't get a
[ __ ] relationship together story my
[ __ ] life that's okay
but if you're like oh the way it always
[ __ ] up my thing story of my life huh
hey you're not that important the zora
neale hurston didn't write your life
here's another one back to the future is
her name and at Becky underscore Elaine
is the actual handle a rare name change
it and not a handle change it back to
the future now how many of the stories
comedians tell during a set are actually
true hmm well since I'm not goddamn
Google I can only guess but I think most
of the [ __ ] it's a good question
actually I mean all of my [ __ ] is true
except you exaggerated a little bit you
know to make it funny
like if you're telling a story about a
[ __ ] giraffe and you're like and then
the giraffe said this you know the draft
didn't say the [ __ ] you kind of can put
it together if it's true or not rarely
do people make [ __ ] up unless it's like
somebody that is obviously doing
one-liners that is like yeah so I just
heard my dad got AIDS and you know it
didn't happen or something you know and
then he makes a joke about AIDS and it's
a joke and it [ __ ] is a misdirection
or something but thanks back to the
future change yet did I just wither a
little pump has a song called Molly so
go out and [ __ ] grab that hey rappers
rap about Molly more do you hate rappers
you should rap a little Molly more cuz
nobody's rapping about Molly so come out
with a song called Molly oh this guy did
cool s so bad for kids this guy Zach
Werner at Z underscore words since
you're from Jersey what are your
thoughts on the pork roll versus Taylor
ham issue hey man Italian hey dude can
you have a [ __ ] cut this guy hey yo
Chris D'Elia since she's from Jersey
what are your thoughts on you know the
old pork roll versus Taylor ham issue
hey sir
fat cop you know to say that on the
outside of a [ __ ] hey yeah this
[ __ ] pork roll you better have a tail
on him hey you know what
give me a Taylor ham maybe the [ __ ] you
talking about this guy please got a pork
roast nah I don't [ __ ] I don't get those
pork rolls
I get those [ __ ] Taylor hams I used
to love Taylor ham when I was a kid dude
when I was a kid I used to [ __ ] go
get telling him that [ __ ] was so salty
and good I'll tell you what man I'm real
set on my ways once I hit that Taylor
ham [ __ ] I never got a [ __ ] pork roll
I knew what I liked done case closed
my hands are tied now that's it case
[ __ ] closed you put something in my
mouth and it tastes delicious Taylor ham
I'll never [ __ ] look at a pork roll
in my in the eyes and I'm serious about
that too and I'll go to [ __ ] war for
that Taylor ham and I'll [ __ ] say
[ __ ] like nah I don't even say [ __ ] like
nah pork rolls [ __ ] suck dick it's
because Taylor ham got to my mouth first
pork rolls needs a better [ __ ] PR
department and I'll tell you what I
don't know about now but back in the 80s
pork roll needed a better [ __ ] PR
department cuz Taylor HAMP was all in my
[ __ ] head I put that [ __ ] right
inside my pink mouth it's a sexual
somehow what the [ __ ] I don't really
know what pork roll is oh it's basically
God well it looks like Taylor ham Taylor
ham is Taylor ham with the [ __ ] side
split and pork roll looks exactly like
Taylor [ __ ] ham I don't know me look
different I don't know me I'm not that
much from Jersey I'm
when I was 12 though bro but please next
time ask a more italian [ __ ] jersey
question hey would you hey we took the
differences between [ __ ] Puerto
Ricans and blacks offensive um puts
Italian hey hey who would you rather not
have in your neighborhood what Ricans
the blacks [ __ ] oh it's the same
thing oh oh oh he's saying oh he's
saying what do you call it pork roll or
tailor him I call it Taylor ham is that
what you're saying I don't know I'm
[ __ ] la living baby I got my [ __ ]
shorts on right now and my shirt off
well it is August so everywhere your
shirt should be off but man I'm just
chilling in LA baby
hey LA why don't you get this syphilis
tsunami billboard out of the [ __ ] way
the STD check org or whatever the check
org syphilis tsunami gross when I'm
driving down the street I don't want to
crash when I see a [ __ ] syphilis
tsunamis got a billboard in LA it's a
syphilis tsunami it's about they want
you to get checked for STDs so you don't
spread syphilis I don't even know
[ __ ] people still got syphilis I mean
I did but I thought that it was a good
game of Thrones disease
I don't like quirky STD billboards like
feel the Bern or there's one get tested
and chill like for Netflix like come on
dude I'm sure there's a got STD one like
the got milk there's gotta be one also
there's one that says go there's one
that says free go back this is free STD
checked I'll give my producer a little
bit of attitude right there free STD
chick org and it's got one that says
chlamydia and then gonorrhea and there
are people's faces and they're kissing
tinder and grinder which is really
probably bad they could sue him
hey tinder get on that dude if you're
gonna start a they're gonna start
extremely sort of soon dude you don't
want to be linked with chlamydia
here's another one we catch them all
like the Pokemon [ __ ] hey it's a
disrespectful for people who are dying
from STDs disrespectful dude I get sent
crazy I just thought this I get sent
crazy DMS obviously and crazy messages
on all the [ __ ] four platforms and
for some reason this one made me laugh
so much
and I don't know if I can describe why
but I'm just gonna read it to you I mean
I get crazy [ __ ] obviously but this and
it's a subtle thing it's not really like
a crazy in-your-face thing I mean the
foreign ones are the best obviously but
I'm not gonna tell you guys name
obviously Chris I think you are the top
comic that I have seen on Sunset
Boulevard first first of all the way the
guys trying to like butter me up is
hilarious also the top comic that he saw
on top like on Sunset Boulevard I'm the
top one which is just so funny because
to me this guy's trying to butter me up
like not like also why should I even say
top comic just I what do you mean what
do you mean you think if you he writes
this whole paragraph and doesn't even
know that this is me know he obviously
knows she's being secured and Sukhoi
about calling me a top comic and
buttering me up so we're already I'm
laughing I am a finance guy and do
seminars and would love to start using
humor in my presentations okay
for killing me alright one of the things
I really like about your style is that
you really seem to be enjoying what
you're doing on stage you build great
characters and then he mentions some of
them and your emotion on stage is
contagious when you laugh I laugh okay
well that's comedy any suggestions for
me this is the work gets good I realized
actually reading into it it seems like
[ __ ] just compliments to me and I'm
like no he seems like I'm [ __ ] just
jerking off on this podcast but this is
the good part any any suggestions for me
on how to do a little of what you do
where do I begin I am taking an acting
class at UCLA I'm taking an acting class
at UCLA and the teacher says that I am
like Jason Bateman a good straight man I
wish I could show you this guy's picture
looks nothing looks nothing like Jason
Bateman looks like the guy you'd think
this guy would look like I think okay
all right I am taking an acting class at
UCLA and the teacher says I am like
Jason Bay Bateman a good straight man I
think he might be saying politely that I
don't have much but I don't have much
emotional range and I am too much in my
head like jumping to conclusions
since Security's coming out so hard you
know his mom we used to beat him and say
he had no emotional range and his too
much in his head and now it's coming out
I think he might be saying politely that
I don't have like why Jason Bateman is a
great actor and what do you why do you
think hey you're like Jason Bateman why
does that make you think oh you mean I'm
too much in my head any suggestions on
how to begin and grow my comedic range
would be appreciated it's a question
mark best wishes and then his name dude
this is so something that what I would
think a finance guy would think about
comedy like I know obviously all of you
finance guys out there don't think about
comedy that way but this is so as a
basic to be like oh hey humor is
something I'd like to use like it's a
[ __ ] cheese grater and then being
like how do i acquire that in our robot
you can't upgrade your system
and then he's like he's an acting class
in UCLA too cuz he's giving because he
gives seminars oh that's really cute man
that's really cute
guess if this guy's white or not of
course he is
guess if he's beige yep
guess of his hairs beige yup I [ __ ]
love it
dude I was in an uber the other day and
this [ __ ] killed me too on the back
of the lubbers on the back of the
driver's seat in my face so I could read
it it said I'm gonna tweet it don't
fertile and thing that he made don't
forget to rate 5 stars it says and then
it had all these [ __ ] things on this
laminate look how busy it is do it look
it's so busy I just showed up my
producers started laughing it says thank
you for your business and then it says
also the I mean this thing is literally
six inches tall and maybe six inches
wide or it's probably four inches tall
and six inches wide don't forget to rate
5 stars and then it has 5 stars make
sure you have all items before leaving
thank you for your business then it says
tips are not required but are greatly
appreciated then it has a hand with
money in it then uh next to that it says
charger available and and under that has
an icon of a battery charging and then
it says next to that seat belts please
and then under that it has the seat belt
sign and then this is my favorite part
if you need anything just let me know
could it wrap that whole thing up with
just a laminate that says if you need
anything just let me know I mean I got a
tweet this dude I mean so much business
on this [ __ ] laminate and then of
course he had one on the other side it
was it was like when I walked in and I
went i sat down and looked at it and I
went ahh out loud because I couldn't
help myself I wish other people were my
uber with me I would have [ __ ] spent
the whole time on the ride pointing to
it with my mouth open looking looking at
the guy I was with uh and I would have
kept doing as we're
driving to the hotel uh and then I would
have said other tips are not hired ah
but the greatly appreciated
you want the Kinkos to make it dude if
you need anything let me know
Oh like I would don't forget to rate 5
stars
it is really cute the guy was really
cute too man
God it made me laugh I watched the
[ __ ] Amanda Knox the I watch the
[ __ ] Amanda Knox thing on on Netflix
I'm halfway through it I was watching it
on the flight because I downloaded it on
Netflix so I could watch it on so I
didn't have to [ __ ] you can get high
streaming services by the way on you can
get high streaming Heist you can now pay
extra on a plane on Delta to stream
stuff did you know that yeah you can
[ __ ] do that it costs 1 million
dollars but you can do it so I just
download the [ __ ] but yeah so that's
pretty cool you knew that that's one of
those things you know that they could
have made it happen [ __ ] years ago
but they didn't and now they're just
charging them for it and that makes me
want to get everybody who works at all
the airlines companies in a [ __ ]
headlock and give him serious nuggies
dude Pauly Shore giving him nuggies and
I was watching the Amanda Knox
documentary finally on Netflix I wanted
to watch it the [ __ ] reporter who
covered the case hey is that guy real
that guy is such a piece I mean such a
piece dude he is such a piece he is such
a piece dude he's like well I think I
think he's British he's like you know
you know I would he created a narrative
and then got [ __ ] Amanda Knox in so
much trouble
because he was such a piece and he was
like you know the people who were
telling me not to do the story are the
same people who were checking on or
checking a story every morning when I
wake up hey that doesn't make them as
bad as you that's like saying I murdered
guy but you're just as bad because you
wanted to hear about it
good gung hay British guy step back a
few step back a little bit but when you
only step just step back a little bit
further a few steps back oh it's just
like a few steps on this yeah just take
a few steps back you created that story
right you've created the narrative that
[ __ ] Amanda Knox kill the person I
just step back a little bit yeah and
that was me uh you know I went through
it really a lot of Depp's to do it just
step back a little bit further a little
bit further okay oh that's right I
forgot me okay cool good dunk dunk I
mean come on you bad purse you piece
it's free conch that should be illegal
you CUDA I mean come on dude I just hit
you with the [ __ ] combo I hit you
with the congratulations combo dude I
hit you with the [ __ ] congratulations
combo excuse me sir
yeah I'll sir coming step back good gunk
you [ __ ] freak hunch should be
illegal you CUDA don't do what if
somebody just turned on the podcast in
that moment you'd literally think it was
ramblings of [ __ ] Charles Manson dude
how about when Charles mattes
oh wait was it Charles Manson the crazy
one when they're like when they're like
what's your favorite color and he's like
oh man
probably relaxing to be that [ __ ]
crazy
oh this is the longest podcast we've
ever done oh man it was so funny I saw
some guy getting so mad BR so mad
because I was doing ads and he was like
yeah the park it used to be good but
he's doing ads now and he's doing and
he's doing ads and it [ __ ] sucks
because you know make the podcast longer
if you're gonna do the ads [ __ ] Chris
but all of the babies [ __ ] went on it
went in on I'm about like hey you want
to work for free
you CUDA so funny and that is the
absolute [ __ ] thing that this cult
bands this
together we aren't we are sending out
elders soon we are where we are
we need these all right now if you're an
elder you have a rank over a baby but
you're still a baby I'm a baby I'm mommy
but I'm the baby you understand what I'm
saying it's like the end of the movie
when you're like oh he was both
I'm telling you that up front no hidden
fees no no no no surprises want you to
know um but yeah that's that so what is
it uh you guys got to remember blue
apron check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron dot-com
/ congrats and square cash you switched
yet cuz it's been like 40 minutes since
I told you to download the free square
cash app for iOS or Android now upcoming
shows I got some upcoming shows coming
up and the merchandise announcements get
made on Twitter so be sure to follow
there you can follow my you can follow
me or also congrats congratulations pod
or its Congrats a pod pod
congratulations pod or you can follow
this store Congrats pod is this Twitter
and my computer my producer messed that
up so one firearm so but yeah bits
Congrats pod is the Twitter and the
hashtag is congratulations pod me he's
still talking in on one farm but my
upcoming shows we got some in Hollywood
California those were sold out Salt Lake
City coming up those are almost sold out
at wise guys comedy club
so get on that a few are sold out
already Phoenix Arizona that is a great
club a great club on there one night and
then I'm in Tempe for the weekend Tempe
is
top two three places favorite places to
go to and do stand-up I love it there
New Brunswick New Jersey Spokane
Washington why am I going Charlotte
North Carolina why
Adelaide what is that Australia si I
don't even what the [ __ ] that is
Adelaide Australia Perth I'm going to
Melbourne I'm going to Sydney Australia
Brisbane Australia
Irvine California and sit in San Jose
California and I'm also adding a city in
Ohio soon you guys those dates are all
available on my website except for the
Ohio one so far but go check out and get
the get the podcast there or get the
podcast there get tickets there and rate
and review this podcast please thank you
very much it helps and if you're a true
baby like you're saying you are and you
know it helps if you're right in review
but man on fire on Netflix watch that if
you haven't watched it watch it and if
you've watched him you like it tell your
friends tweet it and and tell your
friends and and and text your friends to
watch it and some of you guys have
viewing parties that's so cool
I really appreciate all that stuff watch
it next time you're on the plane watch
it I saw I saw a guy today on his iPad
flipping through Netflix he didn't know
I was there or even I don't know who it
was but he was flipping through stuff
and mine came and he [ __ ] flipped
right on by it now not a CUDA not a coot
I'm not gonna say he's not who is it
CUDA for that but definitely not a baby
so but yeah I was like watching it go
and I look on that knee flipped it I was
like wow
guess I'm a piece of [ __ ] and then he
started watching gypsy with Naomi Watts
and not my demo so anyway you guys are
the best
thanks so much for for for [ __ ] being
with me on this [ __ ] great great
great journey
it's just been such a great journey my
producer was just waving air over to his
face because it's so hot he was doing it
like a [ __ ]
okay guys take care
[Music]